vous arrêtez jamais ce type j'ai
toujours l'impression qu'il ya des
bombes dans les poches mais pas que
jeunes comme ça je conserve en passe moi
je suis très friand amoureux aussi
pareil on est des gros fans de 10 dit de
jeu et de leur mère d'heure et moi de
des duos pignon campana pignon lucas
pierre richard gérard depardieu moi j'ai
qu'une référence c'est toi tu es tout un
chacun était chaude
moi je suis plus en plus ouvert que nuit
wilhem qu'un film un autre mais que la
moitié
samoa ouais c'est ça avec avec
d'ailleurs avec un petit corps en mousse
on a envie de la voir dans son bain
aussi à j'ai fait attention à lui à mort
c'est à dire je les protège et deux mois
voilà c'était juste ça évitez toute
méchanceté son encontre le croche pattes
je ne crache pas de facile bki ouais
voilà lui décroché la tête avec les dons
comme un poulet
j'avais rencontré on s'était rencontrés
un soir tu te souviens dans une danse
nocturne
je ne fais pas de la cup a cédé bien
barbu et de revoir police et je suis
tombé sur joey starr qu'il rentrait
comme ça et je dis [ __ ] faut que je te
dise un truc jeu qu'est ce qu'est ce que
c'est super c'est tellement bien ce que
tu as fait où j'étais vraiment on ne
peut plus sincères et là je vais me la
main au paquet et la pluie qu'il fallait
qu'on tourne ensemble un jour
voilà il aida zappa les a lâchés il ya
un quart d'heure ça fait donc deux ans
et et voilà et donc j'étais super
content que ce soit lui parce que je
trouve que c'est super idée de la part
des scénaristes romain lévy matthew et
sud soutenue par les producteurs ensuite
que de nous réunir nous pour un ce genre
de film là est d'ailleurs voilà ça c'est
entendu dans la salle encore lundi c'est
à dire qu'en plus il ya un truc qui fait
que céder des exagérations de nos
personnalités
donc vraiment exagéré pour le coup au
service d'un film service de la comédie
et que donc quand moi je lui met une
claque dans le film donc quand walter
met une claque alfonso il ya quand même
un peu de moi manu qui met une claque à
joey donc tuerie doublement en fait à
chaque fois je vois ce moment et tout
d'ailleurs tout le monde m'en parle
comment sait-on il a réagi quand vous
l'avez claqué finale est allé c'était
écrit un j'ai pas claquer parce que j'ai
eu envie un jeu concours élite les gens
font dit la scène n'est pas finie donc
la baffe à résonner une onde de choc qui
est descendue jusque dans les pieds un
jury très très peur
e
est arrivé oui mais j'ai vu quand même
des situations où ça lui arrivait
souvent je suis là mais ils les recadre
bien et remet vite les choses en place
c'est le temps d'une phrase en fait il
ya des jours avec et des jours sans plus
ouais mais ça a été souvent avec eux
c'est un peu une loterie quoi au fait
c'est ça exactement ça marche à l'humeur
will have ivry lui beaucoup à l'humain
mais notre façon là tous ceux ses fans
qui qui s'installe dans une proximité
tout de suite qu'ils deviennent tactile
et ainsi de suite qu'ils ont pas parce
qu'ils t'ont vu à la télé tu étais un
peu comme là-bas jours qui a coûté ma
télé quoi ils n'hésitent pas à mettre la
main dessus à déplacer quand il faut
machin donc ouais de temps en temps bon
ben voilà c'est ça aide pas quoi c'est
pas bon pour la tête d'un seul homme
non mais ça fait partir un peu de ses
accessoires
enfin voilà comme je comment puis-je aux
propos de grégory plus je sors un album
donc voilà et puis ouais ça m'amuse en
plus ça m'amuse plus tôt j'ai toujours
été toujours été très réfractaire à tout
ça et puis d'un seul coup je sais pas ce
que c'est vrai qu'il ya du jour au
lendemain il s'est réveillé avec un
style à maeva près photo tout c'est ça
ça c'est fait
non c'est rigolo parce qu'en fait il
et puis des poésies et puis choisit son
filtre et là ça nous ça nous il y fait
jouer un mélange de gros nounours plage
pour un ca je suis malheureux vos jupes
ou le faire